[Music]
the vast majority of people who've lost
a limb can still feel it not as a memory
or vague shape but incomplete lifelike
detail they can flex their phantom
fingers and sometimes even feel the
chafe of a watch band or the throb of an
ingrown toenail and astonishingly enough
occasionally even people born without a
limb can feel a phantom so what causes
phantom limb sensations the accuracy of
these apparitions suggests that we have
a map of the body in our brains and the
fact that it's possible for someone
who's never had a limb to feel one
implies we are born with at least the
beginnings of this map but one thing
sets the phantoms that appear after
amputation apart from their
flesh-and-blood predecessors the vast
majority of them are painful to fully
understand phantom limbs and phantom
pain we have to consider the entire
pathway from limb to brain our limbs are
full of sensory neurons responsible for
everything from the textures we feel
with our fingertips to our understanding
of where our bodies are in space neural
pathways carry this sensory input
through the spinal cord and up to the
brain since so much of this path lies
outside the limb itself most of it
remains behind after an amputation but
the loss of a limb alters the way
signals travel at every step of the
pathway at the site of an amputation
severed nerve endings can thicken and
become more sensitive transmitting
distress signals even in response to
mild pressure under normal circumstances
these signals would be curtailed in the
dorsal Horn of the spinal cord for
reasons we don't fully understand after
an amputation there is a loss of this
inhibitory control in the dorsal Horn
and signals can intensify once they pass
through the spinal cord sensory signals
reach the brain they're the
somatosensory cortex processes them the
entire body is mapped in this cortex
sensitive body parts with many nerve
endings like the lips and hands are
represented by the largest areas the
cortical homunculus is a model of the
human body with proportions based on the
size of each body parts representation
in the cortex the amount of cortex
devoted to a specific body part can grow
or shrink based on how much sensory
input the brain receives from that body
part
for example representation of the left
hand is larger in violinists than in
non-violence the brain also increases
cortical representation when a body part
is injured in order to heighten
sensations that alert us to danger this
increased representation can lead to
phantom pain the cortical map is also
most likely responsible for the feeling
of body parts that are no longer there
because they still have representation
in the brain over time this
representation may shrink and the
phantom limb may shrink with it but
phantom limb sensations don't
necessarily disappear on their own
treatment for phantom pain usually
requires a combination of physical
therapy medications for pain management
prosthetics and time a technique called
mirror box therapy can be very helpful
in developing the range of motion and
reducing pain in the phantom limb the
patient places the phantom limb into a
box behind a mirror and the intact limb
in front of the mirror this tricks the
brain into seeing the phantom rather
than just feeling it scientists are
developing virtual reality treatments
that make the experience of mirror box
therapy even more lifelike prosthetics
can also create a similar effect many
patients report pain Prime
when they remove their prosthetics at
night and phantom limbs may in turn help
patients conceptualize prosthetics as
extensions of their bodies and
manipulate them intuitively there are
still many questions about phantom limbs
we don't know why some amputees escape
the pain typically associated with these
apparitions or why some don't have
phantoms at all and further research
into phantom limbs isn't just applicable
to the people who experience them a
deeper understanding of these
apparitions will give us insight into
the work our brains do every day to
build the world as we perceive it
they're an important reminder that the
realities we experience are in fact
subjective have you ever wondered why
humans hiccup or what makes yawning
contagious or if it's bad to hold your
pee check out this playlist to find the
answers to all of these questions and
more and make sure to subscribe to our
channel for new fact-filled animations
each week
[Music]